يُطلق على الجلوكوما هذا اللص المتسلل
للبصر وخلال الشهر الوطني للتوعية بالزرق ،
إنه الوقت المثالي لمعرفة المزيد
عن المرض وفقًا للمراكز الأمريكية
لمكافحة الأمراض
والوقاية منها ، وهو
السبب الرئيسي الثاني للعمى هناك  لا توجد
أعراض ويمكن أن تفقد ما يصل إلى 40٪ من
رؤيتك حتى قبل أن تدرك
ذلك وفقدان البصر دائمًا
- أمريكي وأكثر من 40 عامًا
أو مصابًا بمرض السكري
مهما كانت المخاطر ، تأكد من
اتخاذ خطوات لحماية بصرك ،
احصل على فحص شامل للعين
بحلول سن الأربعين ، تحدث إلى عائلتك لمعرفة
ما إذا كان هناك تاريخ لفقدان البصر
وتأكد من ذلك  الحفاظ على وزن صحي
والتحكم في ضغط الدم إذا تم
اكتشاف الجلوكوما مبكرًا ، يمكنك منع
المزيد من ضعف البصر
بمساعدة قطرات العين
عن طريق الأدوية أو الجراحة عن طريق الفم  من أجل
دقيقة الصحة اليوم أنا ماري مولوني